so
the parts that you can't automate and
turn into a process
so how many parts like that do you think
should remain in a perfect world
and uh for those parts where email is
still
useful what do you recommend those
emails look like how
how should you write emails when should
you send them yeah i think email
email is good for delivering information
right so i think of it like a fax
machine or something you know it's a
really good fax machine so if i need to
send you something and you just send you
a file i need to broadcast a new
policy or something like email's a great
way to do it it's bad for collaboration
so if you're having a conversation like
we're trying to reach a decision on
something i'm trying to learn about
something i'm trying to clarify what
something
what what this is that it's more than
just like a one answer type question
then i think you shouldn't be doing an
email but see here's the thing
like you and i don't talk often and so
we have a kind of new interaction
it's not so sure yeah you have a book
coming out so there's a process
and so on but say there don't you think
there's a lot of novel
interactive experiences yeah i think
it's fine so you could just for every
novel
experience it's okay to have a little
bit of exchange it's fine like i think
it's fine
uh if stuff comes in over the transom or
it's you hear from someone you haven't
heard from in a while
i think oh that's fine i mean that's
that email at its best where it starts
to kill us
is where all of our collaboration is
happening with the back and forth so
when you've moved the bulk of that out
of your inbox
now you're back in that meg ryan movie
like you got mail where it's like all
right
load this up and you wait for the modem
you're like oh we got a message yeah
yeah and there's like sent me a message
this is interesting right you're back to
the aol days
so you're talking about the bulk of the
the business world where
like email has replaced the actual uh
communication
all the communication protocols required
to accomplish anything everything is
just happening with messages so if you
now get most stuff done repeatable
collaborations with
with other processes that don't require
you to check these inboxes then the
inbox can serve like an inbox
which includes hearing from interesting
people right
or sending something hey i don't know if
you saw this i thought you might like it
i think it's great for that
you